foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis so first and a government
attack on nature that's how Wildlife
Charities are reacting this afternoon to
policies that could see house builds and
Commercial development in large swathes
of the countryside now many Charities
are worried the plans could threaten
protected habitats and put clean air
water a national well-being at risk what
councils have until Friday to apply to
host an investment Zone that the
government says will also benefit from
tax incentives and wider support for the
local economy and will be granted after
a rapid selection process so what are we
talking about
while new planning laws and investment
zones were announced on Friday the 23rd
of September that was all during the
mini budget now the zones will have
liberalized planning laws to increase
house building and Commercial
development now they'll Grant tax breaks
such as business rates and stamp Duty
tax relief and the 24 investment zones
can be applied for in areas including
designated Greenbelt areas national
parks and areas of outstanding natural
beauty another deadline for councils to
apply to host an investment zone is on
Friday or joining us now is Sky's
political Chief correspondent John Craig
John thanks for joining us um let's talk
about those plans because Wildlife
Charities former touring ministers and
millions of ordinary people they're
concerned
There's real anger in the countryside
not just from Wildlife groups yes the
former Minister who's been most vocal in
her opposition is Rebecca Powell who was
a minister at defra until a few weeks
ago now there's opposition to fracking
as well but there is particular alarm at
those proposals to allow potentially
potentially
um investment zones to grow in the areas
like the national parks for example now
that has drawn a rebuffer from the
government they insist yes investment
zones are a good thing and will boost
growth but they will not damage the
environment in a statement to Sky News
the government said this investment
zones will deliver the growth jobs and
housing that communities want and need
they're not being imposed by the
governments we're empowering local
places to deliver plans that are right
for their area we will not be
downgrading the strong and established
protections for national parks areas of
outstanding natural beauty and protected
sites national green belt policy will
continue to apply and all proposals must
have consent from local planners or
national park authorities those that do
not will not be taken forward and cannot
become an investment Zone but there is
alarm there's alarm also at the
government's threat to uh scrapbook get
rid of what Liz truss called in her Tory
conference speech EU red tape on
Wildlife measures for example yesterday
in the Sunday Times the national treat
trust Chief that's Hillary McGrady
accusedless Trust of demonizing
conservationists said her members were
outraged and worried about the threat
posed by the new government's policies
John it's such a interesting story isn't
it also though there are comments from
Downing Street saying that prime
minister
doesn't want solar panels on Farmland I
don't know about you but it feels like
the environment is becoming I suppose a
flash point for Liz trust at the moment
it's becoming a real political Battle
Zone because Liz trust has never been a
fan of wind farms now today number 10
has said that they want to encourage
long-term energy and food security we're
looking at regulation and investment the
impacts are farmers to make sure our
projects boost food production and
protect the environment the pm has
spoken about this previously so I said
number 10 which she certainly has back
in 2014 when she was environment
secretary she called her solar Farms a
blight on the landscape and throughout
the hustings in the Summer she was
bitterly critical of wind farms on
agricultural land saying that food
production should take priority okay
John always a pleasure to have you on
the show thank you so much well let's
hear from someone who feels these
investment zones could benefit their
local area
I think we'd be looking to open up uh
sites that do exist in Barrow that have
been undeveloped for some considerable
period of time and uh that will help uh
to draw in uh investment and companies
in into the area where we I think have
some concerns is around if there were to
be a wholesale relaxation of
Environmental
um planning rules and I think we'd want
to look at that very carefully once we
get the the detail of exactly what's
being proposed depending on on what
comes back that there may be some red
lines that unfortunately might mean that
we weren't able to uh to take this
process forward but we'd very much hope
that that wouldn't be the case and
indeed I think you know there's an
argument
uh that uh you know local authorities
ought to be given
uh more power and flexibility
um to uh to make these decisions
themselves rather than it being a
one-size-fits-all from uh from central
government in Whiteville
well the wildlife trusts have been front
and center in our voice seeing their
concerns about these investment zones
and criticizing the government for not
doing enough to keep their commitments
to the environment well I'm joined Now
by their director of public affairs and
marine conservation at Joan Edwards Joan
thanks so much for joining us on the
daily climate show you would have heard
the counselor there local people might
want that investment but you're
concerned about the impact on the
environment
yeah we're really concerned that um
there's little or no regard for nature
conservation in these zones and in fact
you know some of these sites might
contain tripless eyes or national nature
reserves or even be in the green belt or
on national parks and we need to make
sure in the future that these investment
zones don't take away the rules that
protect our nature
and Joan you might have seen that the
rsps B are saying that they're not
ruling out direct action to the
government policy what will you be
telling your members
but I'm not sure the rs3v would do
direct action that's not something us
ngos do but we are calling on all our
members to write to their MPS write to
their local councilors and say we're not
anti-growth the wildlife trusts are not
anti-growth but growth should happen
without damaging the environment
and Joan I'd like to get your thoughts
on there are some people that are saying
that these plans are sort of pitting the
growth of the economy against the
environment what do you think
as I said you know you can have growth
and you can have nature you know we Face
a climate crisis we Face another nature
crises 40 41 of species in the UK are in
Decline 15 of our species face
Extinction the government only a year
ago published the environment act in
that they said they wanted to bring
species back by 2030 and yet at the same
time they're ripping up the rules of
protect our nature
their biggest argument the government
will be saying that they're handing the
power to local communities to make sure
that they can grow their own economies
and and they will say during the the
cost of living crisis that's really
important
well the government's asked for local
authorities to put expressions of
interest in by Friday I'm sorry when you
have a consultation that that's quick
local people won't be involved they
might not even speak to land owners you
know this is a very rushed not fought
out approach and to be honest these are
the sort of things where mistakes can be
made and we don't want to see
um peatland or Marsh or um wildfire
measure has been destroyed in these
investment zones
and very briefly Joan what do you want
to see happen what would you like to see
happen
we want to make sure the rules that we
have to protect nature stay there that
there is no weakening and that if we
have investment zones any protected
sites or protected species in the
investment zones will get the right
protection they deserve
okay Joan Edwards from the wildlife
trust thank you very much for your time
and just before we go we'd like to bring
you that news from Scotland then that
Scotland's first minister pledged to
make Aberdeen The Net Zero capital of
the world in Her speech at the SMP Party
Conference in the city Nicholas sturgeon
went on to announce that the first 22
projects from the country's just
transition fund have received more than
50 million pounds of funding and that
fund is a 10-year commitment from the
Scottish government to support
initiatives in the region which will
help the transition to Net Zero
these projects will support the
production of green hydrogen the
development of wave and tidal technology
and even Pioneer the use of waste from
whiskey to recycle EV batteries
they will focus on the skills our
existing Workforce need to take
advantage of the Renewables Revolution
that's all from us today